Speaker 1: Want to go through some interesting
posts I spotted this morning on The David Pakman
Show sub Reddit. You can join more than 32000
of our viewers and listeners on the sub. Read
it at David Pakman. Dotcom R.E.D.. Edit a couple
of different things. One is, I don't know how
many of you saw this video of Rudy Giuliani
shaving his face with a an electric razor
battery powered, I guess technically at an airport
restaurant. I did see the video. I didn't really
have much to say about it, but it's gotten a bunch
of attention on the sub Reddit. There's something
very sad about it. And we've talked a lot now
about Rudy Giuliani sort of fall from grace.
And it it's not you know, I've said I don't
really feel bad in the sense that he really
brought this on himself. A guy who was widely
praised and beloved, even by some Democrats,
rightly or wrongly, wrongly, after 9/11, he was
mayor of New York City at that point in time
and just squandered all the goodwill, ended
up not only becoming a big vocal supporter of
Donald Trump's, but also going out of his
way like you can casually support Trump,
but you don't have to go around spreading election
lies and passing covid. But he did that and
ultimately was suspended by the bar in Washington,
D.C., I believe, in New York due to reciprocity
and ended up being becoming the target of
investigations, which we don't know ultimately
where where that will end, having his home raided,
having his workplace raided, you know, fighting
multiple times in public during public hearings
and just humiliating himself in other ways.
It's really stuff he's brought on himself. But
as as funny as the video is of Rudy shaving,
sitting there at a table at an airport restaurant,
shaving, it did also kind of bum me out. You know,
he's close to 80 years old. And it just seems like
it's all kind of falling apart for for him. I'm
not saying that he didn't bring it on himself. I'm
just saying the video did bum me out a little bit.
Curious to hear your thoughts. Another
user on The David Pakman Show sub Reddit
posted a Trump has told me it doesn't take
a genius to believe the election was stolen.
I simply said, you are 100 percent right. And I'm
sure that this went over your Trump as friends or
acquaintances head. But you know what I do?
I mean, I've been getting more and more calls
when we take live calls on the show. And even I've
been getting texts from friends about, you know,
I have this anti VAX person at work and I've been
getting into arguments or whatever my advice,
take it for what it take take it for what
you're paying for it, which is nothing. Right.
Right. My advice is increasingly to people
I know personally and to people who call in,
I don't know that I would engage one on one with
these folks. I think it's better to engage with
campaigns and public awareness initiatives
and whatever else in order to get people
understanding facts and understanding whether it's
anti backs or whatever things about the election.
I don't really know that there's much to
gain from these one on one arguments and
the amount of stress and anxiety that I see
it causing people in my audience and people,
people around me, I just don't know that it's
worth it. And so this approach just saying,
you know what, you're right. It doesn't take
a genius to end up believing that Donald Trump
actually won the election. I would go more in
that direction because at some point you've got
to do what's best for yourself. And it seems it's
really bad for a lot of people to be engaging in
fruitless conversations with ignorant people who
have been the targets of weaponized disinformation
and propaganda. That's my sense. But if you think
it just makes sense to keep arguing, let me know.
I'm open to that idea. Lastly, we're starting
to think about and talk about the 2022 midterms
and user highway agitated posted what
would count as a good midterm to you.
We will probably lose the House, but a seven
seat loss would have Republicans at 219
216. Not hard to crawl out of in twenty twenty for
a good midterm could also mean picking up Arizona,
Georgia and New Hampshire governorships. Also
Senate pickups in Pennsylvania, Wisconsin, North
Carolina. We could also flip state legislatures in
Arizona, Michigan, Pennsylvania, North Carolina.
I actually think it's just too early to say
what a good midterm would look like. Obviously,
a good midterm would be one where Republicans
don't take control of the House or Senate. I
know that there are lots of people already
kind of calling it a lost cause and saying
obviously Democrats are going to lose X, Y
and Z. I just think it's too early, you know,
a few months. So ago, we were saying if covid
continues improving and Biden is attached to that,
it could be a really good mid-term. Rachel
bytecode for came on the show and said it
could be OK. It also could be a disaster. In the
aftermath of Afghanistan, it started seeming like,
wow, Democrats are tainted and it's just going to
not go well. But at the same time, voters tend to
have short political memories. I just think it's
too early at this point. I was going over this
is actually interesting. I had a call with our
YouTube rep last week and we were just going over
for planning purposes. When when does the midterm
typically start in terms of media interest?
It's typically way later. It's often not until
April, although more recently it's been more like
March and this year is expected to maybe get going
as early as February. The point is, I think we
probably have at least five or six months. I think
we've got to see what how does covid go through
the fall and winter? Does Joe Biden get another
major accomplishment? Is anybody still talking
about Afghanistan in January, February? I think in
mid-February, we will start to get a sense of what
the midterms are going to look like. And at that
point, I'll tell you what is a sort of good,
better, best than disaster scenario. Join
the discussion at David Pakman Dotcom Read.